i don't care what one thinks about me
or what judgments you want to make about
what happened in the privacy of my own
home in my marriage behind closed doors
i don't presume the average person
should know those things and so i don't
take it personally but even somebody who
is
sure
i'm deserving
of
all this hate in vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation you cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
there's no polite way to say it
the jury
looked at the evidence you presented
they listened to your testimony and they
did not believe you
they thought you were lying
how could
i put it this way
how could they
make a judgment how could they not come
to that conclusion they had sat
in those seats
and heard through over three weeks
of non-stop relentless testimony
from paid
employees
and towards the end of the trial randos
as i say
so you don't blame the jury i don't
blame them it wasn't i i don't blame
them i actually understand he's a
beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor their job is to not be
dazzled by that
their job is to look at the facts and
the evidence
and they did not believe
your testimony or your evidence i
again
how could they after listening to three
and a half weeks of testimony
about how i was a nun credible person
not to believe a word that came out of
my mouth